لا لال لا لا لا لالالالا لا لا لا لا
لاالا لا لالالالا لا لاللا لا هات الكعكه
هات هات هات الكعكه يا ثعلوب الكعكه ليست
معي اين الكعكه اين اين اين الكعكه يا
ثعلوب الكعكه عند النجار اين النجار انه
هناك اين النجار انه في الورش
لا لا لا لا هاتي الكعكه هات هات هات
الكعكه يا نجار الكعكه ليست معي اين
الكعكه اين اين اين الكعكه يا نجار اسالوا
عنها الجزار اين الجزار انه هناك اين
الجزار انه في
الدكان هات الكعكه هات هات هات الكعكه يا
جزار الكعكه ليست معي اين الكعكه اين اين
اين الكعكه يا جزار اسالوا عنها الخضار
اين الخضار لست ادري اين الخضار قد يكون
في المزرعه لا لا لا لا هات الكعكه هات
هات هاتي الكعكه يا خضار الكعكه ليست معي
اين الكعكه اين اين اين الكعكه يا خضار
اسالوا عنها الخباز اين الخباز انه هناك
اين الخباز انه في المخبز هاتي الكعكه هات
هات هات الكعكه يا خباز الكعكه سرقت مني
ومن السارق يا خباز من السارق يا خباز هو
الثعلب المكار اين المكار هرب من هنا اين
المكار انظروا انه هناك لا لا لا لا هاتي
الكعكه هات هات هاتي الكعكه يا مكار
الكعكه في بطني يا ثعلوب السرقه عيب يا
ثعلوب السرقه عيب الكعكه تعجبني تب هذا
انجاز قل هذا لكلاب الحي لا
اوي